all rise for june 18th the national
holiday is on sunday and whether it's a
party or a program you're invited to
join the festivities around the valley
so let's welcome councilwoman pamela
goins-brown to give us all the details
welcome thank you for having me today
i'm excited to be here yes we are we are
ready
we are the same wavelength here
okay now let's let's get into this you
know first and foremost
this was just made a national holiday
just last year right yes so now we're
here celebrating you know just explain
what juneteenth is to everyone who
doesn't know absolutely well juneteenth
is a holiday that celebrates the the
ending of slavery in 1865 and
i know so much about juneteenth because
i went to an hbcu prairie view a m
university
um in prairie view texas and so
juneteenth has always been a big deal in
texas and then the school and the city
is like an hour and a half from
galveston where the um actual
announcement was made that the slaves
were free two and a half years later in
1865 and so it's just a day of
celebration a day of reflecting a day of
just like i said what does that flag
mean with the bloodshed for slavery to
be ended wow i mean it's said to be the
black america's true independence day
absolutely and you know coming from
texas to here you you really bring that
energy and that knowledge to las vegas
so so how are we celebrating here in
around the valley let's let's go through
the rundown well there's celebrations
happening all this week we actually had
a flag raising celebration in north las
vegas yesterday at two locations at our
north las vegas city hall and then at
the martin luther king jr senior center
so that kind of started off the june 10
week in north las vegas there's
activities in the city of henderson the
city of las vegas this weekend and at
our own north las vegas fifth street
brewery it's called mulan brews
so it's going to be just to sit around
and talk about and reflect about what
the true meaning of juneteenth is even
though there's lots of parties and
celebrations it's just a time to say sit
back and say what does this day actually
mean and we celebrate the
accomplishments of african americans
across the united states absolutely it's
a celebration but it's also about
education education absolutely for
everybody so why should everyone of all
cultures and races come together and
celebrate because it's about bringing
people together of like you said of all
races all cultures to understand because
history will never go away right and so
we always need to educate ourselves
about history and the true meaning of
history and juneteenth is just a
significant milestone in our culture and
it's not taught in schools i never
learned about it when i was in school
until i went to texas and i think we
have to bring that to our schools here
in clark county as well yeah especially
in local government as you are you know
are there any changes that you're seeing
within the government that that will
affect our community as well well we now
that this is a holiday we were the first
jurisdiction to formally recognize it as
a holiday so our offices will be closed
on monday and since june 10th is
actually on a sunday this year it will
be observed on mondays and we will do it
the third monday in june of every single
year and so i just think that's huge
because we're one of the largest
minority majority municipalities in the
state right and it's just so much
diversity throughout north las vegas and
las vegas and other cities around around
the state and so it's just very
important to celebrate those differences
well thank you so much councilwoman
pamela um you know also a better another
way to celebrate is to support local
black businesses right absolutely we
have so many here in town the black
business it's very important to support
those and um
share those stories absolutely share
those stories sharing the stories okay
21st annual juneteenth festival the expo
at world market center it's five until
nine pm on saturday june 18th and that
is just one way you can celebrate